- The folks at this quarry
in Claughton near Lancaster
dig up about 60,000 tonnes of shale rock
from the ground every year.
That shale needs to get to the brickworks,
about a mile and a half that way.
Nowadays, you'd have some
fancy underground conveyor belt
or you'd just have trucks loading up
and driving back and forth.
But this quarry opened in the 1920s.
So the solution was a bit different:
an aerial ropeway.
This is the last aerial ropeway
in Britain.
It's nearly a hundred years old.
It needs no fuel and
no electricity to run.
And in 15 years time, it'll be gone.
- This ropeway was
commissioned in the 1920s
but we've been quarrying
from this valley now
for well over 150 years.
An empty bucket arrives, it goes onto
what we call the bull rail,
so that automatically comes off the rope
and it allows the rope
to go around a wheel.
The bucket then is dusted.
If the weather is bad,
the rain adheres to the bucket
and the muck sticks to it.
So that would reduce what
is taken down to the factory
and also would affect
the balance of the rope.
And then it's put under a feeder
where a given amount of material
is put into that bucket,
about a quarter of a tonne.
At that point, another
operative takes the full bucket
from under the feeder and waits
until the correct positioning
of the incoming bucket is in place,
which allows him then to
feed it onto the rope.
That spacing is critical because
of the way the rope works.
It's gravity fed.
- The brickworks is downhill from here
so all the power for this
ropeway comes from gravity.
Put the full buckets of shale on one side,
going down the hill
and the empty buckets on
the other side going up
and you don't need an
engine house or a motor.
You just need brakes
to regulate the speed.
It takes about half an hour for a round trip.
There are about 40 buckets.
This ropeway will move about
300 tonnes of shale every day
with no need for petrol or electricity.
So let's go to the brickworks
at the other end
and see how it works down there.
- As a bucket comes in the other end,
an operator is stood waiting for it.
It comes off the rope at a
given speed onto a bull rail,
from that bull rail, the
operator walks round.
There's a pivot system on the bucket
that tips into a hopper.
At that point, it then feeds
into a dump truck.
The operator then puts the bucket back.
When the correct space is positioned,
he pushes the bucket onto the rope.
It's an art to swing that bucket
and tip it at the right time.
They do walk quite a few miles in a day.
This factory was designed to produce
round-about 42 million bricks annually.
And there was a £4.4 million
investment four years ago
that increased the productivity
up to 50 million.
Claughton produces
frost-resistant product.
It's down to the shale from the quarry,
that's a vital key to it.
The temperature we fire at
and also the durability
of the ceramic bond.
That means we can sell this product
into all extreme weathers.
There's nowhere in the UK we can't sell to
with our durability of
the product at Claughton.
Unfortunately, it has to cross the road.
It's never been known, certainly
in the last 50, 60 years,
to come off at that point,
but it is a possibility.
So we have a steel bridge with
big bucket-catchers on the side
that would prevent that happening.
The rope construction is a
25mm steel rope.
Very difficult to get
contractors these days
who are skilled in splicing
ropes of that size.
We replace the rope every six years.
It's a very, very difficult
process, very old,
the technology's the 1920s, of course.
We did a computer design of
a new ropeway many years ago,
and unbelievably, the
computer matched this design
in terms of trestle heights and weights
to somebody with a
slide rule and a pencil.
- There used to be hundreds
of these ropeways around Britain,
in industrial sites, mines and quarries.
This is the last one still operating
anywhere in the country.
It nearly wasn't, the financial crisis
in the late 2000s
meant the quarry and brickworks
shut down for a few years.
But it was kept in working order
and as of right now,
it's still transporting rock.
But it has an expiry date.
31st December, 2036.
Permission for quarrying
was going to end in 2018
but the local council planning
department granted an extension
because the quarry and
brickworks are still operating.
There's a lot of shale
still in the hill up there
and literally no one objected.
I checked the planning report.
Environmental agencies, local residents,
everyone was, like,
"Yeah fine, keep it running, that works."
Now in theory, that deadline
could be extended again
but the reason they picked 2036
is that by then, the company
will more or less have quarried
everything they can out of that hill.
And one of the conditions
of that time extension
is that once quarrying is finished,
the ropeway has to come down.
The planning report does acknowledge
that it's unique in the country,
it's the only one left in Britain.
There is some heritage value in it,
but, they say, not enough to
justify saving it for posterity.
This isn't like an old railway line where,
if it's left unmaintained,
it'll just slowly, steadily decay.
It could be actively dangerous if the
ropes and towers start to fall apart,
particularly when they run
over a road, just there.
Unless money is constantly spent
to keep it in working order,
it'll decay into an unsafe
blot on the landscape.
Which is fair, but I suspect
when that final day comes
in about 15 years time,
when the last bucket
goes down the ropeway,
there'll be a few people here
to say goodbye to it.
And until then it'll keep moving shale
without needing any fuel at all.
Thank you so much to
all the team at Forterra
for showing me around.
They did ask me to make
clear that the ropeway
is not a tourist attraction.
So if you're in the area
and you want to take
a couple of pictures
from the road, sure!
But then, for their sake,
please keep driving.